let's get into the stimulus let's get
into the stimulus and the reason why i
want to get into the stimulus because of
a conversation i had with a realtor
yesterday
okay so first let me read off what we
have obviously american rescue plan
biden's 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package
the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package
includes direct stimulus payments of
1400
per person extending unemployment
compensation raising the minimum wage
continuing eviction and foreclosure
moratoriums and increasing the child tax
credit while making it refundable
it provides funds for the state and
local governments to help compensate for
lost tax revenue money for schools
from kindergartens through eighth grade
to safely open reopen emmets the
pandemic etc etc etc so
1.9 trillion dollars that's 4 trillion
in the last two years right now in the
last 12 months oh
6.1 when you add it all up when you add
it
yeah some are saying where are we
getting the six trillion because i know
the
the cares act was 2 trillion this is
potentially another
2 trillion 906 billion that was what
january that was uh before trump last
left office so that's fi almost five
trillion well
and then there was other you know
expenditures still taking place so say
five
to six trillion dollars okay yeah no i'm
not questioning it i'm just like we're
trying to
see where all these numbers are this is
all of it pissed into the wind by the
way none of it productive daniel i saw
an article saying the fact that the
20 to 40 of the currency ever printed in
the history of america was printed in
the last 20 20
12 months just like that just like that
and we just assumed that the dollar is
going to maintain its hegemony that it's
going to
maintain its reserve currency status we
take it for granted because we've had it
for 100 years
so what's going to happen because i hear
two different schools of thought and let
me kind of give you both of them let me
give you both of them
one is you know you got these you know
p e ratios that are just ridiculous 1250
tesla okay
you got these shoulder p ratios today
that are indicating that you know
market's going to be facing
99th percentile that's pretty scary to
be there
you got interest rates went up a little
bit which is good to see that taking
place a little bit went up and
you and i were kind of going seeing if
you want if you don't want it but
a guy is sitting the real estate guy i'm
talking to this guy
he is the seller's real estate agent
obviously he's not representing me and
it is a seller's market it is a seller's
market today in florida and it's
ridiculous
so he says let me tell you why i need to
buy this house and why this value this
land is going to double in the next
three to five years i said tell me why
he says because that 1.9 trillion
dollars they put into the economy that's
four trillion dollars last 12 months he
says
inflation's going to the roof and the
value of things that cannot be
duplicated is gonna go to the roof such
as
land okay so he's not selling structure
hard assets he's saying land so you know
we talk about land gold baseball cards
all this other stuff that's going to
art to the roof is this gonna make
the economy and dow go to 40 50 60 000
or is this eventually going to get
america
because it seems like we're on a run
rate i know this whole thing about 128
months that we had economic expansion
kova disrupted it we're back at it again
so if you take cover out it could have
been 140
month economic expansion that we have
what is going to happen with all this
money we're printing
a we were going into recession anyways
in 2020 the federal reserve needed an
excuse to print money
you've never had a year where you have
global trade
world trade contract for 12 months solid
without the the global economy going
into recession that was 2019. we were
headed there anyways
the fed needed an excuse to bail out the
bond market and it got it with kovit it
needed a black swan event and it got it
so that's the one thing that people need
to understand is this was not
the slowdown that we had was not
catalyzed by covet
it wasn't covid was needed for the fed
to come in
with their printing press and the fed
got it they needed the excuse
there was all this repo madness go go
back and look at the end of 2019
when the fed was doing not qe because
there were issues with
overnight lending in america i mean this
is all in the weeds
and wonky but it was happening that
there was real disruption
in the in the overnight markets and the
fed needed an excuse to start pumping
huge amounts of money into the economy
and it got it
it got it with covet and that's why we
are where we are today
because of the printing press but you
cannot
have sustained inflation with 19 million
americans collecting unemployment
benefits you can't
you can have a massive inflation scare
and that's going to benefit your
your real estate not your real estate
agent but the seller's real estate
that's going to benefit them because
it's a great narrative it's fantastic
but it won't be sustained not until you
get these people to work
okay so so what does that mean though it
won't be sustained okay let's get them
back to work people eventually go back
to work you remember when barack obama
said unemployment benefits six months no
12 months no 24 months well this this
new stimulus package pushes it out to
september
sure but eventually people are going to
go back to work they're going to have to
go back to work i know three and a half
million people you're saying
fully lost like permanent permanent job
losses right 300 at recessionary levels
okay but but what i'm saying to you is
like
look if you and i go out there and keep
raising debt
okay we keep getting credit cards and we
get more credit cards
and more credit that's what america is
doing we've been doing it for
for years yeah but but at this level but
how come a massive ridiculous crash
hasn't yet hit what is the key indicator
for that to be taking place
there's no replacement for the dollar
the euro is a joke
italy's a mess they never after we had
the global financial crisis in 2008 2009
our banks were forced to clean up their
balance sheets get rid of the bad debts
that didn't happen in europe japan's
sorry goodbye so there's no replacement
for the dollar until
china gets to be bigger and because of
covid and how we've approached stimulus
spending
versus how china has approached stimulus
spending it was going to be 2030 that
china was the largest economy in the in
the world now it's 2028.
if their currency continues to
appreciate versus the dollar it'll be
2026
five years from now that china is the
bigger economy and then
we'll have a separate discussion about
what's going to replace the dollar and
then your real estate agent
seller guy he's going to be right then
okay my timeline is 20 25 what's your
timeline
for china no no my timeline for the
market to have a
massive collapse like we're gonna feel
the pain i have 20 25. what are you
thinking
once the recognition is out there that
we're not going to be the global
economic superpower
it's game over that's going to take a
few years to happen unpack game over
what does it mean game over well we
benefit because we can borrow at such
low cost because we're the we're the
we're the global reserve currency
so you have all of the
liberals in congress saying there's it
is a free lunch
we can borrow as much as we want 1.9
trillion today
we can have five trillion seven trillion
dollar deficits every year
there's never going to be consequences
for the amount of debt we're taking on
and that works until it stops working
but you have people like janet yellen
and jerome powell who i would
so like i know you have strong feelings
on that j and j so
but they're championing of course they
are
uh all this uh 40 years of falling
interest rates it's all they seem to
think can possibly happen
but they're not studying history they're
not studying the fact that
that great britain lost the pound as
british pound sterling lost its reserve
currency status because
great britain took on too much debt so
if if you start to think that the rules
don't apply after 100 years or so and
that's
it's been a hundred years let me follow
up with that speaking of
studying history so we're familiar what
happened a hundred years ago
world war one uh spanish flu yep
roaring 20s rocking and rolling
prohibition
people are sneaking drinks you know boom
1929
i think it was october was um
it's the start of the great depression
right which lasted all the way to the
1930s so
speaking of history and history
repeating itself you're you're
predicting 1928 potentially
1925 potentially 25 20 20. i'm sorry
2025
2028. are we essentially saying that
that's
potentially what we're in line for is
another
great depression worse than certainly
coveted i'm not so sure that we have a
whole decade in front of us
this is not a repeat of the roaring 20s
if you look back at the price to
earnings ratio in
december of 1920 it was 4.8
this is i'm going to make this really
simple yeah it was 4.8 in december
of 1920 100 years later in december of
2020
it was seven times that level say that
one more time say that one more time
stocks were seven
times more expensive coming into 2021
than they were going into 1921.
seven times more expensive so you can't
convince me that we're at the precipice
of
a roaring decade for the for the u.s
economy
what do you mean stocks are seven times
more expensive the price to earnings
ratio the cape
schiller that looks back over was 4.8
times earnings in december 1920.
it was seven times that level in
december of the year 2020. yeah yeah
that
that's that's a con so so here's so for
me
i trust math more than i trust
enthusiasts well then you trust what i
just said seven times
more expensive that's exactly where i'm
at i'm at the math side i lean i
trust matt right when it comes down to
things like this math is going to tell
you what the future is going to look
like you just have to look at the right
math right
but but the part i think about is the
following so you know when
world war one when germany had the debt
that they had to pay off with the
reparations they would they they're like
dude we don't have this kind of money to
pass it they went quietly behind closers
and what did they do
they started printing money printing
money printing money to pay off the debt
they paid it up but hyperinflation took
germany to crazy levels and then
boom they took him a while to recover
from it
why are so many brilliant minds in
finance
so optimistic about the direction the
economy is going why are they so
optimistic
you got to talk your book you're saying
they're trying to sell a book or is that
oh yeah your book of business you have
to i mean
it's their jobs to pump up the market
it's their jobs to keep people invested
in the stock market it's their jobs to
say
for the long haul you're always getting
you're always going to get paid off
what's your
level of trust for jerome powell
and or janet yellen your level of trust
10 out of 10 is
they're the best i love them one is i
wouldn't trust them right so i'm going
to send you a copy of a book called fed
up
okay what you wrote i know i'm familiar
with it it's got janet's words in it
okay okay what are you saying for the
people that haven't read the book
she's a uc berkeley educated labor
economist who's in charge of the biggest
economy in the world
who doesn't understand the financial
system like she should
and she is in a place
where she can finally lay the groundwork
to to policy in the united states
not benefiting the top one percent but
benefiting
everybody which will ignite inflation
like you've never seen
it's that's a bad thing it's the idea of
helicopter money it's the idea of
getting money directly to the people
as opposed to saying there'll be a
trickle-down effect if we make
lending easier if we make borrowing
costs lower
then companies are going to borrow and
spend and hire that
is and has not worked instead they
bought back their shares
and 42 billion you've seen the
financialization of america which is
non-productive
it does not create jobs so janet yellen
is is bitter
that she was at the head of the fed
when this wealth effect when wealth
inequality was widening
if she has the power now to reopen the
federal reserve act of 1913
to allow for direct deposits to the
people
there's no wall street in between
there's no intermediary you're going to
get money directly to the people
and you want inflation you'll get
inflation then so
by the way it was 25 billion that
berkshire hathaway bought back of their
shares but
because there's nothing to buy it it's
your map it's too expensive yeah well
it's also banking on yourself like you
know you know you know where the value
is yeah you know where the value is
yeah i i don't know to me uh i
and that was the most so disappointing
letter warren buffett i mean he's 90 i
get it but
he didn't he didn't take a stand on
anything controversial
it was a wanton seriously america is the
best bet on american
american fixed income is this you're
coming out of the most controversial
presidential election your murder rates
going through the roof
the the the the country's clearly in a
crisis mode
and you say nothing about what
the ills of the country when you have
what would you expect them to say like
what would you want to hear from
a generation ago he said that share
buybacks were weapons
of mass destruction excuse me
derivatives were weapons of mass
destruction and he derided sheer
buybacks
in his prior life because he was like if
if you've got a bunch of people's money
and you can't put it to work
and and make investments and grow their
money then what do you what are you
doing in business
that was his attitude about share
buybacks years ago
and he took a stand in saying that
derivatives were
weapons of mass destruction he didn't
say anything that was like
wow controversial nothing he was like
apple's
you know when we're talking uh uh
economy and maths
so you're saying you're gonna get what
you're gonna get which is
inflation like you you just you just
said that before we went but you have to
have a crisis you can't just
willy-nilly reopen the federal reserve
act you have to have something happen
to where there's nomura big bank out of
japan
said that every 20 cents of the dollar
that's printed of stimulus
goes into the economy in other words 80
doesn't there's they were saying that
the multiplier effect of stimulus
spending
is crashing we know that 53 percent of
the last stimulus bill was saved
so what good does it do to spend all of
this money
if it's not being injected into the
economy if it's not creating jobs
and that i think is where the democrats
are
really really missing the message
because they say they want to do
infrastructure spending they say that
there's another bill coming
but they're ramming this all through
with reconciliation there's not a single
person in the gop
much to say nothing of moderate
democrats who are on board with what
they're doing
so they're going to burn every damn
bridge before they get to
true stimulus spending that creates jobs
i mean you could fall into a damn
pothole in new york city if you're in a
small car
and be lost forever there's bridges that
are collapsing
and you've got high-speed railways in
china that go zillions of miles an hour
and they're in the middle of
constructing 30 airports and getting
ready to eat the united states as lunch
and we can't even pass
fiscal spending that creates jobs and
repairs our infrastructure i mean fdr
wrote the book
i'm no huge fdr fan but it was a
public-private partnership
and it created generations plural of
productivity and job creation
and we're giving people money to not
work whoa
winning at a seven percent unemployment
though at a seven percent unemployment
we're not talking about that eleven
percent ten percent that's seven percent
unemployment we've had seven percent
many many different times we have and
it's not a bad level it's it's 6.3
and that's all good and well but that's
because so many people have left the
workforce
so that's your math if you've got people
who've given up
that's why you have a 6.3 unemployment
rate but still 19 million americans
collecting
unemployment benefits and that's why
you've got this stimulus spending is
just to kind of cr
we're going to have the best economic
growth in america in 2021 since 1983.
it'll be five six percent gdp we're
going to have a blockbuster year that's
what they've been projecting six percent
you can't jam two trillion dollars into
the economy and not expect gdp to grow
it's gonna grow okay
so then it's not going to create jobs so
you're going to come out at the other
end of it going oh god we we need more
stimulus spending
and more yet and more yet and so you're
going to get the stephanie
keltons of the world i think so you
don't think this 1.9 is the last 1.9
we're doing the next two three years
no so you think there's more 1.9 coming
up
at least a trillion dollar
infrastructure bill right a trillion no
no no i'm talking
about a trillion doesn't even address i
mean look there's there's there's two
three trillion dollars just to do the
repairs
just in there and there's no number two
modernization i'm talking about repairs
and then potential green energy bill
right oh god help me well let's not
let's
let's still stay on this because here's
here's my thoughts so
dow's right now what the 30 what 31 okay
so let's say it's at 31.
if it's gonna be a six percent gdp
and if if you don't think things are
going to turn around in the next you
know
three four years say 2025 2026 when
china
whose plan they came up with made in
2025 made in china 2025 their plan was
to be the number one superpower by 2025.
they're on track to be that by 2025 2026
you know where do you see doubt go in
the next 12 24 months do you see it
going to 40 50 60
you know i'm that that i don't do
do are you optimistic it's going to be
going i think that looks the way
it's going it's going to go higher i
think we have a correction in front of
us that we're in the midst of right now
and between the
money printing that we have to come the
liquidity that's going to be injected in
the economy you could certainly see a
correction and then another run-up
another melt-up i i i see i don't see
this slowing down the next couple years
you don't see this happening but that's
just liquidity you're just talking about
you're just you can't have a drought if
it doesn't stop raining
and the fed's going to keep printing
money as long as we have license to do
so because we have
king dollar which has been weaponized
it's actually a great analogy can't have
a drought if it's keep raining
they're making it rain they're making it
rain they're straight up they're you
know they're
getting killed making it rain you've got
janet yellen in the house i mean
the the the rain makers dj janet yeah
making it rain even worse i mean she
would
when she was the chair of the fed and
she would go in front of congress and do
her testimony and they would ask her
about financial regulation
her eyeballs would roll into the back of
her head she was so bored
i'm sorry but steve mnuchin was a master
at what he did
hmm and he's a minutian fan i'm
not saying i'm a minutian fan i'm saying
he understood his job
and he understood the plumbing of the
financial system and he understood
what needed to keep the wheels on the
bus and keep it going
that's not jenny allen but what about
jerome powell
i know you've been uh pretty outspoken
about janet yellen what are your
thoughts on jerome i mean look
his net worth is somewhere between 150
million dollars i think he's done wow
february 2022 his his term is up
and the woman who donated to hillary
clinton lail brainerd
is poised to rise that's who you think
is going to be the next chairman of the
fed chairwoman of the fed
i think so well we got prediction here
but if you're enjoying
the podcast so far smash that subscribe
button you mean moreno thank you for the
hundred dollars you just gave to the
podcast so now
short sellers and elon musk you know
last week we talked about
i asked a question from adam and tom i
said who's
next to be permanently banned from
twitter
that's as you know that's you know like
trump you know you got trump personality
permanently banned from twitter
and i brought up to uh ilamas because
you know some of the stuff he talks
about hey he's very influential
very very influential he's got a lot
more look what he did to bitcoin then he
plays with bitcoin look what he does
with short him he's just playing
non-stop right so is what he's doing
okay is what he's doing with twitter is
is he that brilliant where he's not
crossing the line and he's just playing
games with the market to show how much
influence he has
well if it was elon musk in a vacuum
maybe so
but he's the pied piper so he has plenty
of people following
every move he makes so you can't say
bitcoin's the next it girl and then a
few days later be like
just kidding you're toying with
small investors and speaking of
elizabeth warren
so and you've got gary gensler coming in
in the uh
in the securities and exchange
commission and he's looking
into these influential type of voices
so but i'm going to push back for just
two seconds and
say it was a strange it was a bad line
that was crossed when they took donald
trump off twitter
it just was it set a bad precedent
because now we can have these
conversations about who's next
and that's not what free speech is all
about it's not
so you're for trump staying on
i i think that the precedent that was
set
is a bad thing it's kind of like the
democrats saying kind of like aoc
cut lover saying we need to get rid of
the filibuster it's like well wait a
minute
if if the midterms flip the house and
the senate in 2022 which is
perfectly viable then and you got rid of
the filibuster how are you going to like
that then
so you need to watch what you do because
you're setting the next generation of
precedent when you do it
and it could come back to bite you in
the ass so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye